se faire une place parmi les grands et
si possible se faire connaître au delà
des yvelines à côté des flammarion
grasset ou robert laffont au salon du
livre les maisons d'édition
indépendantes sont aussi présentes elles
sont un peu plus de 700 en ile de france
parmi elles inédit créé il ya 15 ans à
montigny le bretonneux et qui publie
tous les ans six ou sept romans en
échange avec les gens qui passent et qui
s'arrêtent devant nos livres et on peut
leur parler de nos livres ils parlent de
leurs goûts de lecture etc
c'est aussi très intéressant d'un point
de vue professionnel pour échanger avec
les confrères va pas avoir une foule qui
ne se bat pas
pour ce faire signer vos trous noirs
mais c'est bien parce que bon
ça permet de rencontrer du monde aussi
ou de revoir des gens qu'on n'a pas vu
depuis très longtemps profité de la
notoriété du salon et de ses
opportunités c'est également l'ambition
des éditions versaillaise il adore à
quelques livres de la sa directrice
bénéficie elle aussi du stand mise à
disposition par la région ile-de-france
400 m² pour rencontrer un public
inhabituel porteur d'un autre regard tu
rencontres les publics il dit avant oui
c'est que j'aime pas la couverture
ça peut arriver ça peut arriver en
détrempée
on a l'occasion de parler donc
d'améliorer aussi notre travail en
moyenne chaque année les français
dépensent 116 euros dans leur budget
livres pour un chiffre d'affaires de
près de 4 milliards d'euros une manne
financière dont profitent largement
l'ile-de-france la région accapare à
elle toute seule un tiers de cette somme